[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ]
it's so amazing this [ __ ] consuming and
cut it he likes black I'm sorry
you like let's flap now you have a [ __ ]
with a slap would you date a slack not
answer any question that's the answer
but I don't like the answer you don't
understand the question
I think I understand it what is it about
the question that difficult for you is
it are these really the most important
topics for you afternoon okay I'm Nessa
so all of a sudden you're dumb
no I really don't know no I don't okay I
won't accept it Paul
you do know what you won't say amazing
oh do you know what a [ __ ] is when you
see what no hado mail in the mail
[Music]
you know what a beta male you know so
you're not been married you have you're
not married never been there are no kids
in our there I've never been married
that's true I'm not currently married of
course and I don't have children at this
time do you date I do you date you in to
exclusively right oh why don't you date
me I'm not attracted to me I don't see
anything wrong with it
oh yeah what is love I I don't do the
dictionary definitions you don't ya know
you do you know what love is I think you
know love when you see it yeah you love
me not as a team yeah why not
well I love you thank you are you
surprised you love me I don't really
know you
that's ridiculous would I no longer be
beta you've become Apple
[Music]
[Applause]